بلادنا تواجه اكبر مؤامره في تاريخها
الحديث
تستهدف كيان وهويه وتراث مصير شعبنا
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم على وقع معارك متواصله
البرهان يتهم حمى بجرائم حرب ويقول ان
السوداني يواجه اكبر مؤامره في تاريخه
الحديث وحاكم دارفور يحذر من تداعيات
الحرب في الاقليم ويقول انها اسفرت عن
نزوح ثلاثه ملايين ولجوء مليون اخر الى
دول الجوار
قاده الانقلاب في النيجر يتهمون الرئيس
بازون بالخيانات العظمى ويؤكدون عزمهم
محاكمته وبرلمان اكواس يرسله وفدا الى
نيام لبحث سبل حل الازمه دبلوماسيا في وقت
يبحث فيه مجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي
تعليق عضويه النيجر في الاتحاد الافريقي
وسط اختلافات بين اعضائه
العفو الدوليه تقول ان الذكرى العاشره
لمذبحه رابعه هي تذكير صارخ بان الافلات
من العقاب عن القتل الجماعي لمئات الاشخاص
قد مكن لهجوم شامل على المعارضه السلبيه
المنظمه ذكرت في تقرير بعنوان عقد من
العرض انما وصفتها بالمذبحه قد مهدت لتاكل
كافه ضمانات المحاكمه العادله وعاقبتها
معامله وحشيه لا توصف في السجون طوال
العقد الماضي حسب وصفها
البرازيلي نيماردا سيلفا يوافق على
الانتقال الى نادي الهلال السعودي قادمه
من باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي مصادر صحفيه
اكدت ان نيمار سينهي الفحص الطبي اليوم في
باريس ثم سيوقع بعدها في صفوف الهلال بعقد
يمتد لموسمين الى اللقاء